[Music]
one of the most challenging aspects of
building an interactive app is
controlling the flow of data that's why
you might often hear developers debate
over best practices around state
management and while flutter and
firebase both provide some awesome tools
to work with reactive real-time data
it's still not easy in today's video I
want to show you some of my favorite
patterns for apps that have complex data
flow needs with things like firebase
authentic cited to show you how a
library called provider can dramatically
reduce the complexity of your code if
you're new here like and subscribe and
you can find the full source code on
fire ship i/o and I should also mention
that I just recently released my own
flutter app on iOS and Android it allows
you to take quizzes along with my
youtube videos as well as my full
flutter course which was just released a
couple days ago part of the course is
free but consider becoming a pro member
to get the full experience now when it
comes to state management with flutter
and firebase
I've tried a whole bunch of different
approaches and there are a lot of
different solutions that work so it
often just comes down to the developers
preference so let me give you an idea of
some of the things that I really value
on the subject first I want a good
separation of concerns from the business
logic and presentation logic in other
words I don't want to have a whole bunch
of logic related to the retrieval of
data embedded somewhere in the widget
tree the second thing I value is being
able to share data easily throughout the
widget tree I might need to access my
firebase user in 10 different screens
and I definitely don't want to be
listening to a stream manually in 10
different state full widgets and third I
like to try to avoid boilerplate code
there's a lot of really good and popular
state management solutions out there but
they tend to require a lot of
configuration and in most cases I just
prefer to have simple conventions over
explicit configuration now the provider
package for flutter does a really good
job of meeting my needs and all three of
these areas and all it really does is
provides syntactic sugar for inherited
widget as well as some other low-level
building blocks and flutter like stream
builder and change notifier it allows
you to expose a value or as we'll see in
this video a stream and then access the
value in any of the descendant widgets
as simple as that sounds it actually
leads to some very profound benefits
especially when you need to compose
multiple streams together for example
the firebase user with some related data
in the database we can demonstrate that
in the simple demo
where the user logs in and then they can
create a record in the database related
to their user ID and then they can add
additional documents in a sub collection
to that root document now before we get
into the actual source code I want to
first show you some of the challenges
that you might face when working with
firebase and flutter so firebase exposes
streams for both user authentication and
firestore and the most painful way to
manage those streams is manually in your
own stateful widget so first of all we
have quite a bit of boilerplate here
just to get the staple widget set up and
then we need to set a property for the
stream subscription and then also the
data that we eventually want to show in
the UI when the widget is first
initialized we'll go ahead and subscribe
to our stream and then we'll call set
state to update the data whenever emits
a new value this is a stream to read
data from buyer store and so it could
cost money and it could also be sending
a lot of data downstream so we need to
make sure to dispose of it when this
widget is no longer needed that means we
need to call a subscription cancel in
our dispose lifecycle hood now finally
we can go down here to our build method
and display the data and notice how
we're using bracket notation to call the
title key on a map so this data is
dynamic but the text widget requires a
string as its argument so if the
database returns null then our text
widget is going to fail so we have no
type safety here and dart is not very
forgiving when it comes to types because
it does runtime type checking now we can
already make a huge improvement to this
code by refactoring everything into a
stream builder so this time you can see
here I have a stateless widget and now
I'm going to wrap our code in this
stream builder and just a side note you
can always do that with the refactor
tool in vs code which is a huge
time-saver now the stream builder widget
takes a stream as its argument and it
will automatically subscribe to the
stream then give us access to the data
inside this builder function in addition
it will cancel the subscription
automatically when this widget is
removed from the tree now we still don't
have any type safety on the data payload
so oftentimes what you'll do is use
double question marks here to make sure
that it always returns a default value
with the proper type the stream builder
is awesome but what if we also need
access to the user inside of the build
method that's also a stream so what will
most likely do is wrap this in another
stream builder although we could map
everything together into a single stream
but that's also not exactly easy as your
app becomes more complex you might need
the data from multiple streams at the
same time and you might have one stream
that depends on another stream it's very
common for a fire store document reads
who depend on the currently logged in
user stream and then you might need that
data in a deeply nested widget and the
only way to get that data down is to
pass the properties down through all the
children so now that we have a good
understanding of the problem let's take
a look at how provider solves it if you
remember I mentioned earlier that
provider is syntactic sugar for
inherited widget so that means we can
use it the same way we might use a theme
in flutter where we set up our data at
one point and then we use it in a child
and that child will look up the widget
tree until it finds the first instance
of that type and use that as the data
source now we're only going to be
focused on streams in this video because
that's the way firebase returns
real-time data but keep in mind provider
can also handle just regular values in
your app as you can see here I'm in the
root of the application and I'm going to
wrap my material app in a multi provider
multi provider is really convenient
because it allows you to setup multiple
streams or multiple values and then
share them without having to nest
widgets you just add all the values you
want to share into a list one thing you
might want to do if you use firebase
authentication is observe the current
user throughout the entire application
we can do that by setting up a stream
provider here and you'll notice that
it's types to the firebase user type
which comes from firebase and then we
pass it the stream that actually
contains that data now the real magic of
this approach is that we can now treat
the firebase user as if it were a
synchronous value throughout the entire
app if we go down here to the stateless
widget we can just access the user
directly inside the build method by
calling provider of context with the
firebase user type so now anytime we
want to access the user we can do it
with a single line of code without
needing to set up a stream builder so we
can determine if the user is logged in
or not by seeing if the user object is
null and then I want to take a second
here to show you a cool trick in dart
2.3 you'll notice we're using
conditional logic directly in the
children list for the column and then we
can also combine this with the new
spread syntax to create a partial list
that will only be visible to the logged
in user
so basically we're saying if the users
logged in show this list of widgets but
if the user is not logged in show this
list of widgets so it's bold concise and
readable and that already gives us a
fully functioning authentication system
the user logs in and the app
automatically reacts because that widget
that depends on the user from the
provide
we'll rerender when it emits a new value
so it makes the user authentication just
work like magic but it's a little more
tricky when we start talking about fire
store because fire store always returns
data as a map and unlike typescript we
can't just apply an interface to a map
and dart so that means we need a way to
deserialize our data from a map into an
actual dart class so what we'll do here
is just define a couple of classes that
define the shape of the data this is
going to benefit us in several ways it's
going to give us intellisense when we're
actually working with these data models
in our code and it's also going to
ensure that we have appropriate defaults
with the proper data type like I
mentioned before if you pass a text
widget anything other than a string it's
going to fail but writing a data model
like this will help you alleviate that
problem and give you a single source of
truth to manage it right now we just
have two immutable classes that do
nothing more than instantiate some
properties but what I want to show you
now is how to deserialize this data from
either a map or a fire stored document
when you use a map it's a little more
flexible because you can also use it to
deserialize regular json data or some
other data source like maybe from dart
HTTP this from map constructor will take
the map that we get from fires store as
its argument then it will simply take
the values on that map and set them as
properties on this class and we can also
use double question marks here to set
some default values now this process is
kind of tedious but it does give your
data a strong schema and it makes
working with data in your widgets a lot
more user friendly mostly because you
have intellisense on everything and you
have some confidence that you're going
to be passing the right data types to
your widgets at runtime if you want to
make your constructor a little more
specialized you might name it from fire
store and instead pass it the document
snapshot this way you have access to the
document ID which can be useful when
working with collections because you
don't automatically have the ID in the
return data but the drawback here is
that your constructor is now more
specialized so wouldn't work with other
things like just plain JSON and just to
make this clear your data model should
match what you have in fires store so
here we have a hit points value which is
a number and then a couple of strings so
the data model is only responsible for
creating an instance with the proper
data shape what we'll do now is define a
database service which is responsible
for the actual business logic of
retrieving
these items from the database and
deserializing them to the appropriate
class this is just a plain dark class
and I would recommend keeping this class
stateless and have it focused on
exposing methods that return data to you
for example if we want to get one of the
hero documents typed to the superhero
class we can make a reference to the
heroes collection with the document ID
and then we can return a superhero
instance with the front map constructor
with the snapshot data now when we
perform this read from the database
instead of getting a dynamic map we'll
get an actual class instance of
superhero but we actually want to listen
to this document as a real-time stream
so we'll use the map operator on a
stream to map that to an instance of the
superhero now we can also do this with a
list for example we want to make a query
to firestore for a list of weapon
documents this code is a little more
challenging because we're being returned
with a list of snapshots then we need to
take that list and then map each item in
the list down to the instance that we
want which is a weapon now I'd recommend
doing other things in your database
service as well like performing writes
to the database but the general idea
here is that you're taking all of the
business logic of working with a
database outside of your widget tree now
that we have all this setup done we can
see the true power of provider in our
code now we already have access to the
current user in our widget so we can
easily use it to create related streams
by simply passing that value as an
argument to our database service for
this part of the UI I'm just using
stream builder so that's still super
convenient and in this case that will
give us access to the hero document
that's related to that user ID but with
the provider package we can also use a
stream provider elsewhere in the widget
tree this is especially useful if you
have your widgets broken down into a lot
of small pieces of UI because it means
you can use your data in all of those
widgets without having to pass in the
properties manually and you also don't
have to create any additional stream
builders or subscriptions to the stream
all the data is just there and ready for
you to use I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to go into even more advanced
concepts than this consider enrolling in
the full course on fighter ship il
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]
[Music]